le 7 8 c'est chaque soir à 18h du lundi
au jeudi pour faire le point sur
l'actualité du département l'actualité
des Yvelines nous étions aujourd'hui
Porte de Versailles à Paris pour une
édition spéciale pour faire le point sur
l'actualité des constructeurs yvelin
mais l'actualité c'est également la
démission du maire Jacques lolliose le
maire socialiste de manie elle est à
Meaux a décidé de passer la main c'était
lors d'un conseil municipal qui s'est
tenu vendredi soir les explications de
Johanna Soudry
ce conseil municipal est un conseil
particulier
une page de l'histoire de notre commune
se tourne
après 35 ans de dévouement Jacques
Claudio a choisi de permettre le
renouvellement dans la stabilité et la
continuité Bertrand Houillon a été élu
maire de Magny-les-Hameaux lors d'un
conseil municipal exceptionnel vendredi
28 septembre après quatre mandats
Jacques lollios a décidé de démissionner
pour laisser sa place à un ancien maire
adjoint pour moi il était important que
donc on puisse passer donc à une autre
génération de quelqu'un qui avait
effectivement donc la bonne connaissance
donc de la ville et parce que donc être
maire donc vous savez ces six ans 6 ans
ses cours et c'est long à la fois si on
veut réaliser il faut donc s'orienter
parce que c'est comme ça il faut
s'orienter sur voir au minimum de
mandats donc Bertrand vu son âge à 36
ans et il est en capacité de pouvoir
poursuivre effectivement cette activité
si effectivement les mailles quoi mais
quoi ils donnent confiance Jacques le
lieu de démissionne pas pour des
problèmes de santé mais afin de préparer
des prochaines élections municipales en
mars 2014 Bertrand Houillon sera le
candidat de gauche les 18 mois à venir
vont être 18 mois de travail de
continuité finalement cette élection on
pourrait dire c'est tout simplement la
continuité de notre action on n'a pas de
changement
autre que les personnes au niveau de
l'exécutif et on continue notre
programme avec toujours le même
enthousiasme toujours la même
disponibilité de l'ensemble de
l'ensemble de notre équipe majoritaire
du conseil municipal parmi les dossiers
au programme celui de la réhabilitation
par l'OPI voit des logements du quartier
du Buisson mais aussi la continuité des
circulations douces
nouveau maire s'engage à défendre les
services publics et notamment la Poste
qui menace de supprimer le service de
tri et de distribution sur la ville lors
de ce conseil exceptionnel Bertrand
Houillon a vite endossé son rôle de mère
pour remettre la médaille d'or de la
ville à Jacques lolliose au-delà de
l'émotion de la gauche l'absence de
l'opposition s'est fait remarquer aucun
des cinq conseillers municipaux de
l'opposition n'était présent vendredi
soir qu'est-ce que ça veut dire c'est ça
la démocratie c'est ça la démocratie
donc il y a une convocation de conseil
municipal pour élire le nouveau maire et
donc ces gens donc le défaut se
complètement ça veut dire que finalement
il n'accepte pas finalement qu'il y ait
une majorité donc au niveau d'un côté
municipal il n'accepte pas qu'il puisse
y avoir des changements un déni de
démocratie à son tour évoqués par le
collectif Mani nouvel énergie dans un
communiqué manie nouvelle énergie
collectif visant au renouveau politique
de manileamo dénonce un véritable déni
de démocratie et rappelle à Jacques
lolliose Bertrand Houillon et l'ensemble
de l'actuel majorité de gauche que les
seuls qui trancheront seront les Manic
et manicoises en mars 2014 lors des
élections municipales outre le maire un
nouvel adjoint a été élu à l'urbanisme
et au logement j'entends serai les
devenus de 8e adjoint de Bertrand
Houillon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et Jacques Claudio sera sur le plateau
du 7 8 dans nos locaux de Guyancourt
cette fois-ci mardi à 18h en direct
c'est la fin de cette édition spéciale
consacrée et réalisé au Salon de
l'Automobile à Paris Porte de Versailles
merci aux équipes sur place Maxime Le
Maine Patrick Jacques de dixmu d'Alice
Gastine et Valérie Auribault merci
également au réalisateur qui ont
travaillé sur cette émission je vous
retrouve donc demain en direct à 18h
depuis Guyancourt et n'oubliez pas le
Salon de l'automobile c'est jusqu'au 14
octobre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]